hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to unforgiving uh
northern him now we just came face-to
ass with the giant troll and it didn't
go so well for us in fact we might be
mentally scarred about that but now that
we got our brother back we're gonna be
able to sneak our way through these
trees and get our way through Oh Oh No
what are you talking about what could
possibly be wrong
oh the hypnotic ass of death okay
alright okay alright
you lead the way bro I'll follow you to
the ends of the earth and then I'll
probably die but besides that oh where
to go wow wow it's quite a walk you got
there bro you're uh you you're really
working out those glutes I can see the
quads are burning quite deeply then I
don't know bro I mean maybe it's
friendly seems awfully friendly munching
on whatever the hell it's got there hey
buddy
doing great I mean you smell really bad
and your family probably eights you and
no one wants to be around you and you
should probably invest in some deodorant
you know personal hygiene is obviously
not a high priority for you but you're
doing great keep it up man I'm proud of
you not really I don't know oh thanks
for waiting bro yeah I can see that walk
didn't get you very far
mmm oh boy that guy is ugly and I don't
know what he's munching on but it's a
slice wow I have was going fast all of a
sudden Oh should I be not okay alright
never mind it's time to run I guess okay
here we go then thank you bro for giving
me warning about that one and where the
hell are we going is a question like how
did he survive on his own I barely know
how I survived on man in fact if I
remember correctly I didn't survive on
my own oh now is the time it's safe for
flashlights you sure about that bro huh
yeah I think they are soda Nina look so
then häôs go get a full of sauna sockets
with this one yeah no joke we gotta keep
movin but wait what is it have those
been different ones that I've been
seeing or I thought it was the same one
ah
so we're running into a distinct problem
if there's gonna be more than one of
those big tall thingies because there's
also other monsters in the woods and if
you feel like you should be worried
about that you I never understood how
trolls reproduce so and and you know
what I guess I don't want to find out
their den of oh we're going it we're
going into their den of pleasures as I
was about to say yeah bro I ain't too
sure about this either I'm sure we'll be
safe in there this obviously looks like
it's made by natural occurrences and not
by a giant troll biting its way through
the ground can you imagine just a giant
worm with a troll head just like
blasting its way through a mountain oh
no bueno no bueno uh okay okay
thanks bro man I love hanging out with
you sure do love our vacations where you
kidnap me somehow mysteriously mira a
horrible troll infested island that's my
favorite type of the day that we have
together Oh No the bridge is out well
who built this bridge because that's the
biggest question that I have right now
there's a ton of infrastructure on this
island and it had to have originated
from somewhere are you waiting for me
really bro do I have to go alright fine
[ __ ] so man my butt is taking a beating
in this game I am sliding all over the
blow hey how's it going there I guess
you don't need to slide then yeah it's
so bizarre like the elements that are in
here are obviously from a time when
industrialization was this thing there's
like mining equipment is railyards it's
not exactly modern for like the time
period where we all have cell phones I'm
assuming that this game is set in modern
times but there's still an element
that's missing like why is all this here
where could they have been possibly
going that there would have been human
civilizations that didn't know didn't
notice the giant naked trolls walking
around completely big flaw Polly
swinging all over the place and no one
noticed like not a single goddamn person
noticed that there were giant rolls and
also shadow monsters in the marshes of
which people built bridges and it was
like a car thing and a big old box train
that moved across the ocean like those
are things that didn't just pop up
people built those along with their
sacrifice books and whatnot and whathave
you you don't need you don't babe bro
run faster bro Oh
so they look back I should not look back
okay all right I'm aware of that bro I'm
aware how about you go faster you deuce
I'm going
currently going yes that's exactly what
I'm doing
why would I bro was it the sound of my
brother's bone snapping or was that this
is the most horrible thing I've ever
seen
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do we do Oh
[Applause]
why oh my god ye know what in the hell
was that all why did I do that why oh oh
my god why am I doing this why in the
world why am i do why why
why why why did I do that why why for
what reason did I pull out his eyeball
and his tongue
what Swedish tradition is that cuz I am
NOT following that I have no idea
oh I am I have no idea I am at a loss I
am completely in the dark this whole
situation I don't know what I can't why
can't I move anymore well I can't
suddenly I can't even move my mouse is
dead that is the answer to that question
I bi excuse me I had to but I'm still
gonna talk about what why what what in
the world it's in and why I have no idea
like why I I can understand like mercy
killing but I guess I left him to suffer
too long and then he died anyway and
then I didn't help him and so and in my
madness and my grief I like I pulled out
his eye so I can build like a bone
effigy de to keep him in my heart
ie a you that's that is a level of I'm
not sure I gotta get a good a USB cable
to charge my mouse I just whoo it's
wireless mouse this is gonna be just
long enough I don't even know I had the
longer one I don't know where I went
okay all right
carrying on game on all right okay what
does this say
quarantine high risk of infection okay
all right well I got a tongue to protect
me and my brothers always watching over
me because I got his eyeball that's what
I got his eyeball okay it is dark I
can't see [ __ ]
what is that fire on the mountain what
is that sir volcano over there oh yeah
okay I'm over it I'm over it I've I've
recovered I mean I haven't recovered
recovered but I've recovered enough that
well I mean no I haven't Rick I don't
think anything is gonna make me recover
that I've played been playing or games
for years and that that just I think
that that finally asked me out they
messed me up okay what do we get here
nakon by the altar the wrath of Freya
awoke and she conjured fire from her
wrath and burned his eyes and hands so
that he could never play the magic harp
again lovely story boy finds large
footprints in the forest apparently that
was newsworthy apparently that was front
page news worthy ah the large man the
large man who resides in the woods is
ferocious and very dangerous ivory is
very easy to spot and to hear because of
his large Bazzi and clumsy footsteps
Odin's knowledge okay thank you for that
Odin you are of great help some light
reading yes I guess okay all right hmm
ah cans of rust I see my favorite
delicacy in these trying times whoo
that's horrible not that this that's
horrible
yep that is horrible I want her I don't
can we just agree to disagree on that
one cuz wow that's gonna give me
nightmares okay there's a key though got
a key in a tongue and an eye that's
really handy okay this is a scary room
ah yep and the music kicked up it's a
bad room yep there's a real bad room I
don't know what's with that statue in
the window that's bad that is very bad
don't like that sacrifice again do I
have a flashlight or anything you want
to run that by me again hey smarty pants
and you are give me an idea what the
hell is making that clatter out there
huh you guys want to do with that oh
okay all right no matter there I got a
key those two that's awfully nice for me
nice tiny tree oh no that's a that's a
that's a human tree
[Music]
okay you know what
nope I'm gonna go with the big nope on
that one uh Helberg phone Oh an outhouse
double good for me looks like it's all
coming up it's like it's coming up
markiplier over here I can do that do
what do that together and of course you
want star band huh
I love the Fiat ass has a little hard on
it little window so you can see
someone's taking a [ __ ] yeah okay I'm
gonna yup over here you guys yup that
away I'll keep you yep
I don't know about that I'm pretty
smoking hot you can't even get close to
these looks hey you don't know what kind
of crazy I am I rip my own brother's
eyeball and tongue out you don't want to
know how badly I will mess you up if you
come near my man you can have them you
know what you can have them you can have
them not that pretty I'm pretty ugly I'm
plain like any any definition
all right okay ah matches ah excellent I
like that give that a shakey shake ah
good excellent
all righty I've got matches witches
what'd you say all right gotcha
light a match light her up baby I've got
a match
all right what do we got here okay
she wants to keep me sure she does
whatever you say buddy all right okay
hello how are you my brother's dead
yeah I don't trust literally any of that
literally none of okay well my my match
just burnt my whole hand off that's what
I can assume a pin there alrighty then
I'm gonna crouch down and go through
this hole in the ground cuz that's how I
roll baby
anybody else want to give me a rough
time here because I am so ready to kill
anybody that tries to get in my way not
out of some vengeance
just because I'll be so scared I'll just
come out winging
oh hi hello how are you
okay well that's awful Oh what happened
to your fingers I mean what happened to
the rest ear but what happened to your
fingers okay that's awful that's
terrible
ah pony ah nice ass okay all right good
great great great
I uh okay I think I know this song all
right you got you guys ready for it are
you ready for it
whoo ragnar play our song so we know
it's here the key to the droppage and
gate is with the guardian okay all right
wait Alma fingers yeah why not do it
then I get it yeah okay all right I'm
outta here all right all right stay
around the banner gasps okay all right
see I get all died all the musicians
coming with me on this trip I'm gonna
light that candle those next to that
tree person and I'm pretty sure they're
not gonna light on fire and die horribly
screaming and then I'm gonna feel bad
about that because to be perfectly
honest I don't feel bad about anything
these days considering the things I've
already done to survive oh you mean I
didn't need to do that to survive oh
that's weird
okay all right then whatever all right
let's light that bad boy up all right
give me a give me a good old light on
that yep this is what I wanted
I don't understand how that worked but
all right I don't want to sing that song
you'll hear that
[Music]
okay all right okay all right horrible
horrible very horrible uh horrible yes
extremely horrible incredibly horrible
the worst thing I've ever seen
yep all the above I'm gonna go with all
the above is what that is
gee Josh I should check the outhouse
first before my candle runs out anybody
enter by taking a [ __ ] ooh me Molly okay
all right good job Molly glad you think
so highly is it for yourself to put up
self-portrait by the [ __ ]
I snuck in here why did that one take so
many tries I don't like that hi please
tell me that was an animal it's
everywhere
what is fire uh-huh okay a root
Alchemist the vanishing of Ruth helped
the vist but wait this is for root
alphabets right here what does that mean
Oh a light in this room a feats and
achievements of Grem NER righty-ho
whoever the hell grim near is God fat
what's in the bottom drawer nothing all
right
sacrifice they sure do love their
sacrifice here
there was I don't even know how to i'll
buy and and we're doing even need one of
these not oh well
makes me feel safe hello ah lovely
I see you gave the baby boos oh no
that's a double beer bottle I don't want
to play in the forest anymore yeah I
wonder why everybody got turned into
trees which is kind of bad ah most
platoon perfect can I wear this as a hat
hmm
maybe I should dig my hand in here to
really see if there's any buried
treasure down deep something tells me
there's some good to be gleaned from
that all right what do we have here
nothing whatever ah
besties forehead yup besties for all Ted
forever indeed homeschooling teaching
children in the home is yeah okay
alright hymns and birds love hymns and
ballads so I got bored with that
homeschooling thing oh good it's someone
doing kettle bells ringing oh god that
joke was so spicy I had to drop my match
alright sploosh alright let's get out of
this hellhole we don't need to be here
anymore
I got places to be now what am I looking
for exactly
I think I'm looking for some kind of an
instrument that's gonna help me play
some music that's gonna help me get
across a group get across a bridge and
hopefully get to where I need to go
because the year may be 1942 for these
people but for some reason magic still
works nowadays
oh hey lady or so sassy gamma move on
all right SIA oh hello and how is there
still power by the way that's another
big question than I have here did I go
in some weird time loop some weird time
thing okay alright lady
alright hey over here for a good time
you say okay alright that's disturbing
as hell oh my god that is the worst
thing I've ever seen
yeesh yep that's oh I hate every second
of looking at you
yep every single second of looking at
you is the worst thing I've ever done
okay all right well you have a lovely
day being a horribly transformed into a
monstrous tree person and I'll have a
lovely day trying to figure out a way to
get into this house that's locked for
mysterious reasons everybody should know
that privacy goes out the window when
you've got horrible demons at the door
we don't have a key yeah whatever okay
I've got yeah many matches I don't know
what that is but I got yeah many okay oh
wait no wait wait did I make a big
circle or something Oh what is this
hello altar Oh weird alrighty then -
great okay
mmm lovely oh okay all right hmm
little ones affray uh that's nice clock
tower very sassy phone I don't believe
you drawbridge of storage and all of the
ha
so is that the Clocktower okay that's
the Clocktower that's where I am right
now so I need to go smeb I need to go to
find the blacksmith oh my god
can it be true the rumors are they
really real probably not you know but
here I go anyway can't believe I'm
finally finding the blue guys I found
the blacksmith after all these years I
can't believe it SMED oh come on SMED my
good buddies things sound a lot creepier
when you whisper them in Swedish hello
anybody in here mr. blacksmith SMED good
buddy how you doing Smitty oh I got a mo
a stick band or a rope or whatever that
might be
he's nice cop all right woman found
walking naked in the forest is that a
good thing or a bad thing is like what
what don't you have first I thought it
was my roof yeah have drove fishing
together what's newsworthy and just look
at this town oh we found a woman walk
around you naked
no no why yeah I thought printed on a
newspaper oh good Oh what the hell a
chimney oh it's buried okay well this
was pointless I'm glad I finally found
you after all these years but I can't
help but say mildly underwhelming my
friend okay so I got a farm
I gotta find
[Music]
okay all right that's an option to do
how about have you ever considered not
that thing that you just did which was
creepy and terrible and gonna give me
nightmares have you ever thought about
that one no okay all right just just
suggesting it you know what is that
oh that's new oh I didn't notice that oh
oh what is what am i leaving looking at
I'm looking at ah
oh that a it's dead thing oh that's what
that was okay it's a dead whatever it
doesn't matter what it is it's a dead
thing then those are that's bad because
that's recent
then great okay all right I am in a
weird time warp okay all right glad we
clarified that you're gonna go to the
hall to harbor now the little ones of
Freya I'm sure all of my worst fears
have suddenly been confirmed this is the
worst thing the little ones affray are
gonna haunt my dreams as I remember in
the previous horror games that I played
such as like dead space
okay all right
okey-dokey then right you have fun doing
whatever the hell you're talking about
I'm gonna go over here now I'm gonna go
into this place and be very scared
probably hello little ones have you all
been taken away
oh you yo all right who is this another
chamber putz a spittoon if you will
oh good blood on the wall oh that's
wonderful cinnamon bun recipe fun on a
bun
[Music]
thank you ah for yes thank you Oh Oh
cold nice goat okay all right I wanted
to get out of here now oh yeah ooh ah I
don't like it okay all right gonna go in
here now Oh spittoons
you know all these oh he comes at night
oh that's okay no yeah I don't like that
you know how uh these kids love chewing
tobacco all right what do we got here
mommy's crying mommy's crying but
someone else is happy that I can plainly
see what was that oh oh boy oh boy these
people
[Music]
nope no mommy doesn't believe me but I
saw him I think I believe you okay
that's all the time I got for this
episode I'm gonna carry this on I'm
gonna go to the hall of the harp and
then I'm gonna see what all the fuss is
about over there but thank you everybody
so much for watching we're gonna get
through this together we're gonna get
through it slowly but surely so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always we'll see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]